en el noreste de Ucrania pagó un precio
muy alto por su ubicación está muy cerca
de la frontera con Bielorrusia y también
de Rusia y hasta que llegaron muy rápido
las tropas de Moscú después de la
invasión el 24 de febrero sin embargo
gracias a la reacción del ejército y de
los voluntarios lograron mantenerlos por
fuera de la ciudad la asediaron pero no
la tomaron la atacaron como se ven pero
aún así lograron mantenerla hasta
comienzos de abril cuando las tropas
rusas se retiraron una mezcla de
Patriotismo coraje y heroísmo nos
defendemos desde el 2014 así que ya
teníamos experiencia
las autoridades contabilizaron ocho mil
viviendas que quedaron destruidas el 90%
de ellas civiles incluido el estadio de
la ciudad que había sido remodelado
meses antes y la biblioteca
casi todos los habitantes hemos recibido
entrenamientos en primeros auxilios
el gobierno no nos está apoyando
nos da recomendaciones de que hacer como
evacuar como escondernos Según la clase
de ataques
después de abrir gran parte de la
población regresó para los temores han
vuelto a aumentar en las últimas semanas
especialmente desde que se conoció que
10.000 integrantes del ejército ruso
están asentados en Bielorrusia donde
realizan ejercicios militares con las
tropas de ese país el gobierno ucraniano
alertado sobre la posibilidad Aunque
remota de una nueva incursión el año
pasado estábamos aquí no escapamos
volvimos a abrir el café el 17 de abril
y desde entonces tuvimos muchos muchos
clientes muchos militares que estaban
muy felices de vernos nos abrazábamos
entre nosotros pero lo que vivimos fue
muy miedoso y no sé si podré sobrevivir
a algo así nuevamente